i mean you've i mean this guy was
building like doing construction on
beverly hills 90210 then was on 24 and
lost and
first of all when you were working on
beverly hills 90210 did you ever
see the stars like the big stars and how
old were you when that happened
i was uh i was out of college so i was
in
97 87 90
i was probably 25 did you see dylan and
those guys
i'm friends with all those guys now i
mean i just talked i missed i'm just
missed jason he was up here shooting
private eyes
and because of the cove and stuff we
weren't able to actually
um hook up and we were gonna we're gonna
at one point we said all right before
you get out of town we're gonna we're
gonna
go grab a coffee and take a walk and you
know be outside and search the distance
but be able to to hang out and it wound
up not happening cause my work schedule
up here got so insane but
um i've i've loosely kept in touch with
with everyone else a little more with
jason i was very close friends with
luke our kids grew up together
um uh the ladies i see in passing
uh every once in a while um gabrielle is
in my neighborhood and we're we're
friends
um uh that's great
i just spoke to him recently i can't
keep in touch with all those guys
basically i mean when you you see a guy
your colleague your peer like somebody
like and i i don't even
know we're gonna go there but you know
after luke's passing it's so sudden
and you're like i mean to me that just
puts everything in perspective and makes
you think like hey it really is and
these these thoughts are sort of
ephemeral like i wish you think like
that
i mean obviously you can't dwell on
things but to know that hey
like that it's over like that it is over
so what do we do we gotta live every day
and we gotta
and you think those things and then you
forget that you kind of go back to your
same right we all do that
it's like new year's resolution it's
like oh i'm gonna work out and i'm gonna
i'm gonna not masturbate as much and i i
don't know why i went there
but you know what i'm saying so uh i
mean how do you approach those things
when you see a colleague or a friend
like that how do you deal with that
stuff are you pretty
like solid like in terms of like
upbringing and how you deal with
problems because i'm kind of all over
the place and i'm
i'm amazing i think i'm kind of all over
the place too you know
sometimes different parts of your life
come into focus in different ways
and um that was huge you know the loop
thing
and i i don't i don't uh i'm perfectly
fine talking about this now
um but at the time i wasn't uh
i wasn't talking about um my friendship
with him and what an amazing person he
was because there were a lot of people
who um
were taking advantage of that
um was there time to get in the press
and that sounds shitty
but i saw it and i'm not talking about
his close friends or their
close friends out there is that that
were
much closer than me yeah that loved that
man
and and you know gave wonderful tributes
so i'm not talking about that at all but
because i wasn't that close to him
um i was very aware that this this is
you know my relationship with with luke
was was very close and very personal
and wasn't in the press so why should my
reaction to his passing
be in the press yeah if for no other
reason than to put me in the press
yeah that just seemed kind of up
to me so i i didn't
i didn't do any of that so i haven't
really talked about um
his passing and uh for me it was a
huge a huge wake-up call
because we we're you know we're close in
age i'm older
which just even makes more like holy
yeah um
but he passed from the same thing that
my mother-in-law had just passed from
two years ago uh so like six months
uh or eight months prior to his passing
i don't know i get that
uh but i don't care um
not shortly after my mother-in-law
passed luke passed
um and it was the same exact thing and i
was just like
like that that's not that's supposed to
happen to people who are much much older
you